[Music]
uh real quick hey hey papa papa
Dave Rubin was on the show Papa oh God I
forgot we had to get to this
why is he why is Brandon Schaub look
like he's about to train the rock to
[ __ ] the Rocky Balboa to fight yo my man
is a gay Dime Piece my man got them good
hair plugs Papa
a forum or a YouTube comment and hate on
somebody else never might make sure you
don't want okay okay hold on let's let's
go back talk about the haters huh well I
gotta go back a little bit I I won those
before sorry just be like like you have
to be super religious or absolute Dave
Rubin blocked me not because I said
anything about him other than he has
hair plugs and he blocked me for that
lead pro-life or whatever and that's
what I think the future is there's going
to be a move to the center right and it
will be basically like Libertarians and
conservatives and I would say
Libertarians aren't in the center right
okay some old school liberals that sort
of sounds like Libertarians are so
[ __ ] far right that you would be
terrified of if they really knew what
they believed yeah they don't believe in
any government you are yeah that will
try to battle it out and they'll so you
want you want like a secular
conservatism it sounds like because
you're afraid to say if if you say
you're conservative people will think
you have to be if I say I'm Republican
people immediately think I should put
women in jail for having an abortion
which I don't right no but no but that
they don't though but that's not true
that's just your crazy friends in L.A
you're because you're about to think
Brian you're worried about what your
crazy friends in LA are thinking who
gives a [ __ ] what they think
right I am willing to under I I'm really
willing to say that even even if you
were to describe abortion as ultimately
murder because what what happens with
technology is a fetus is going to be
able to live on its own at the point of
conception eventually yeah I mean we
will have artificial wounds we can get
into all of this we'll have artificial
wombs and stuff like that I my argument
is we put a price on human life every
single day of course uh if you really
are that that if human life is that
sacred to you then um lower the speed
limit to 15 miles an hour are you are
are you you CIA handling [ __ ] [ __ ]
are you implying that speed limits being
too high are the same as voluntarily
killing a baby
also when when millions and millions and
millions and millions of people are
killed
we'll have that talk but you know and a
lot of these people that killed die in
car accidents it's their own fault
and and and we'll save all the lives I
promise and if you're caught drinking
and driving uh you lose your license
forever and you're in jail forever if
you want to be Draconian and save lives
we can do that we're not gonna but we're
not talking about that you're not
talking about it we're talking about
murder yeah this is murder it's not
negligence it's not a mistake it's not
eating a hot dog and having heart
disease it's you don't actually you
don't accidentally get an abortion it's
terminating another person's life
I don't know [ __ ] you never heard of
a [ __ ] tripping and falling on a coat
hanger well I mean that's you know I'm
gonna do that yeah well yeah once at a
Men's Warehouse Society has to play that
game so in my opinion but it was like a
really poorly won Men's Warehouse
and it was a freak accident it was
[ __ ] weird I'm willing to I'm willing
to accept that that it when I say I'm
pro-choice it comes with very
uncomfortable this is he gonna dig the
book or what I mean this is you're
making the same you're making the same
time
well well you know what's funny about
the title is that don't think because it
comes from you and you're not funny
this book it's not like I expected them
to do Nazi Germany 1941 throw it in
bonfires but there actually is a version
of book burning happening these you know
spread it and these underground trolls
they're all trying to assault our Amazon
reviews and all the online retailers to
crush our reviews and all that yeah and
I get it but listen I want to be fair
here let's stop pretending like you know
the left wing is only doing it to the
right wing because every time there's a
black little mermaid or they cast
somebody wrong they review bomb the
movies too so let's not pretending like
this Warfare has been pretty even on
both sides at least I'd like to think
you know hey Dave how many times did you
uh ask people to join you and um
uh canceling Disney plus oh three times
that's right three times in one year you
throw it in a canceled Disney plus and
you never did not only did he throw
exactly it's like because he because he
he kept posting a screenshot that he had
just canceled it but somebody pointed
out like yeah but you said you've
canceled it like three times and look I
know you're gay and the problem is gay
people love Disney you know
so to tell the gay guy not to watch
Disney it's like to tell a gay guy to be
responsible I was gonna say not to be
responsible sexually but yeah also that
it's just it's hard to do stuff because
what is that what when you burn a book
why do you burn a book you don't want
the ideas getting out there so why would
you overload that if I'm stuck in a
cabin and there's no more wood and the
only thing in there is books can I burn
it then
or or whatever freezing to death
basically yeah can I then now burn a
book I don't know what the rules are
Dave why don't you tell me a guy who
used to be a liberal an opportunity he's
a conservative because it's easier to
break in through that Medium as a shitty
half-assed comic and people pretend
you're a good interviewer but you're not
especially when you're a gay guy wait to
be a novelty wait he's gay first time
hearing of it
Amazon with fake reviews because you
don't want people to buy the book so
it's like these guys are literally
proving the point but even that doesn't
matter do you know why why what's the
age did you say what's the age of your
average hater this is the only way these
people think huh
no Brian is trying to have a
conversation with him at least even if
he is a [ __ ] he's trying to have a
conversation about that kind of stuff
and Brandon's like well so average how
much does your average hater weigh you
think I could beat up an average hater
so what's the average age of his hater
I'm guessing 67. no young that would be
nice because they would be much less
tech savvy I know I'm I'm guessing that
it's it's this like 18 19 maybe even 15
like it's this it's this underground
internet thing every time a troll comes
after me with one of these crazy things
I always think man all you need to do is
read Jordan's book just get your stuff
in order and you will know yeah yeah
yeah yeah no no assistant Jordan
Peterson's book that sounds good the guy
who got so bad to benzos he had to go to
a Russian detox facility look I don't
think it's not even Russia it was like
Croatia like one of those weird places
and I don't dislike Jordan Peterson but
I also come on let's be realistic here
you know
Reuben is the biggest evil on the planet
you might disagree with none of these
people are going to save you
me on some of my politics what a waste
of time time
Reuben still being allowed to pretend
like they're canceled he's never been
canceled
he's never said anything cancelable he's
so milk toast yeah he pretends like he's
[ __ ] riding on the edges man and he's
not no he's not he sent her right what
he said
porn would be more of a less waste of
time yeah I mean but watch porn like I'm
sure I don't know you that well but I'm
sure you've never got on uh a forum or
YouTube comment and hate on somebody
else never like make sure you don't
watch it now no no you don't do that
what you do is you have big gay lion
Mark Harley do it for you that way your
hands are clean because the real reason
papa is not a lot on social media
anymore is because his wife wife told
him you can't be [ __ ] on there
anymore because I know what you're doing
on there so then Mar then what happens
is you you you're gonna type hate on
there you mean like Mark Carly didn't
got your [ __ ] whiskey brand uh
Instagram taken down stop it stop it
okay
I don't I don't associate with anybody
who's ever done that I don't know anyone
who makes a good amount of money who's
ever done that
um I think we do pretty well I mean
we're not you know we're not rich we're
not we're not getting rich off Food
Truck reviews yeah we're doing all right
but you know
I'm happy with themselves yeah well
that's what it is but that's what I mean
about the purpose thing so why would you
read Jordan's book it's like get some
purpose actually the nicest things that
people have said to me about my book is
that it that it's a much more simple
version of Jordan's book because it's
because you're stupid
because you're stupid yeah
Jordan Jordan is this and I know a lot
of people are retirements who sort of
shot he's not man these are these little
grifters that [ __ ] get into these
little spaces and it happens all the
time
this guy ain't genuine about [ __ ] this
guy was just somebody that couldn't be a
gay comic so he became a gay
conservative
yeah this is a 30-year because it's
easier to be a gay conservative and to
be a gay comic because there's a lot of
gay Comics there's not that many people
it's a thing yeah if you want to be a
gay liberal and try to like it just yeah
nobody would have cared
man I'm just saying if canceled means an
average of [ __ ] 2 000 extra so we
average of [ __ ] over 300 000 views
but I'd like to be canceled you know I
would love to be canceled
clinical psychologist who's giving you
serious he's historical and and I think
I got some of that from uh through
osmosis with him and I was able to
translate it into just language that
that we can all understand so you got it
through osmosis through something that's
not real got it and I've been around a
lot of these great people it's like it's
like Rogan you guys we all sit down with
these cool people and I think if you
gotta your head roughly on straight if
you can incorporate some of those ideas
into your life then you have no excuses
to cult this is the cult mentality and I
know people go this is this is the
problem with this kind of stuff man
the problem with this kind of stuff is
then it becomes the intellectual dark
web where you have people like Sam
Harris talking about how it's okay to
break the laws as long as Trump's not
president
that's the issue those those are the
great thinkers you associate with yeah
oh good old Sam Harris yeah your buddies
in the intellectual dark web
what you want is JFK that's not what
your country can do for you ask what you
can do for your country but the ship has
sailed think about how reverse that is
then Bernie Bernie says this is the
government we can give you a ton of [ __ ]
and we're going to keep giving it are
you still fighting Bernie hey can I can
I break something down to these people
real quick just really [ __ ] quick
don't don't start you you're still doing
the burning stuff like it's 2012. you
know or 2013 2014.
Bernie's not a threat even if everything
Bernie says is [ __ ] [ __ ] and it
is Bernie's not a threat you want to
know why because as we've seen when they
try to make Hillary president they don't
want Bernie to win because Bernie's not
going to be nice to corporations and the
current new liberals love corporations
so you could stop trying to beat up
Bernie don't worry nobody hates Bernie
more than Democrats yeah exactly nobody
hates Bernie more than the DNC I prom
there's not a republican Republican
started remember when Trump was saying
yeah I'll be honest I kind of feel bad
for Bernie they kind of [ __ ] him and I
was like yeah right I kind of feel bad
like I think he sucks and ideas are
[ __ ] poison but remember he also
straight up said he's like I'd rather
face you know he's like I'd rather face
Hillary but like you know he's like
Bernie would actually probably give me a
run for my money it's true though he's
straight up you should go with Bernie
you know give me a better fight
if none of it makes sense and we're
going to pick 15 minimum wage but
someone else might say 20 like it's all
bananas made up stuff by a guy who's
literally never accomplished anything I
I am more of a successful I have no
doubt that both of you are more
successful businessmen than Bernie
Sanders ever was or will will be did you
see that
what did you did you tend to that's what
Brandon said yeah
listen to Brendan
no doubt that both of you are more
successful businessmen than Bernie
Sanders ever was or will I'm richer than
him hey man yeah no I don't it's at the
point he's making a point I know we're
talking about Bernie Sanders
I have no doubt that in your future you
will be a more successful businessman
than Bernie Sanders ever will be Bernie
has never accomplished anything but but
think how reverse ask not what your
country can do for you oh my God it's
the same basic [ __ ]
no it's not even what he's saying is
wrong it's just he's still talking he's
still using the 2016 vernacular and
talking points it does it bro forget JFK
dude no [ __ ] don't [ __ ] matter no
more all right we're in the end games
now Dave so why don't you shave your
[ __ ] hair plugs off go back to you
back with your gay husband and hope you
have a [ __ ] Panic Room because you
know who's gonna go first the little
sissies so good luck bud good luck to
you and your California family that's
all I can tell you
I it's it's it's it's this why are we
still talking like this and Brandon's a
[ __ ] so he doesn't know anything and
Brian Collins dad's in the CIA so he
knows too much you know you ask what you
can do for your country he was a
Democrat he was a liberal Democrat
president who by the way was like oh my
God are the Liberals though the real
racist too they are you know they're the
[ __ ] party of the clan level the
demon rats [ __ ] shut up hey hey Royce
hey Royce did you did you know that the
parties never switched I know man I know
laughs uh just basic [ __ ] talking
points and look it's something we like
to check and go home it's right but it's
like
these may be the three the three dimmest
people that have ever been on a podcast
together you know and them too
also anti-warrin for cutting taxes he so
if Bernie walked up there and said that
yeah he really did that's the whole
other thing but but if Bernie walked on
stage and said that they would hang him
it is the reverse of what Bernie says so
that was so when I say there's nothing
left on the left the Democrats
look Biden is their nominee Biden has
dementia
that was a good one there's nothing left
on the left yeah he's an orator
he's really good at this I don't know
why you don't like him more bro he's
[ __ ] every mean my mom post on
Facebook stop it's not Corona he really
is Facebook to the person hey that was
very bizarre yourself
great job guys great podcast can
somebody talk just one at a time please
the coffin sneeze too now I'm like
I'm like give a [ __ ] yeah but but I'm
not in a risk category so so uh hashtag
vibrant hashtag crazy virility but you
know I I don't know not obese hashtag
Famous Last Words yeah
ventilator uh yeah and you take over the
show yeah man I I um I I just I just am
I'm really wonder man I really wonder
about where this is going to take us and
there's a new world on the horizon that
is it I think that we have no idea what
just happened something so bananas
happen that none of us can even fathom
how crazy it is what this has done to
the economy
God you're so plain he really is just
cave vanilla ice cream yeah repair plugs
you're you're you're you're no no no I
know worse gay fat-free frozen yogurt
with hair plugs yeah because even
vanilla ice cream is still could be look
it's still ice cream like a really good
Haagen-Dazs vanilla ice cream versus
what a non-fat vanilla frozen yogurt
come on
he's just the [ __ ] worst bro it's
exhausting they're all the worst I'm
tired of all of them yeah